Our next guests aren't your typical Drew-Gooders.
They made headlines when they spent an entire weekend
picking up dog doo-doo
in 20 degree weather
on the streets of Hoboken, New Jersey.
And we've all been there,
out on a stroll and you look down
and someone forgot to clean up after their dog.
And well, if this has ever been you,
you're going to freak out at what these Drew-Gooders did
to clean up the sidewalks in their neighborhood.
Just take a look.
So this is just one bag.
(plastic bags rustling)
Bag two.
(audience applauding)
Please welcome Luis Perez And Nyomie Nievez.
How you doing?
I mean, why do you do what you do?
I mean, pun intended.
Yeah, right.
Ah, Ross would love that.
So we own a pet care service called Luv on a Harness
in Hoboken, New Jersey.
We walk about 5 to 10 dogs at a time.
And back in February, we had a really bad snow storm.
So we decided to take initiative in our own hands,
and a few weeks later in March we went to the streets
and we started picking up some of the dog droppings
that were left behind.
And we spent about six hours on a Saturday
and six hours on a Sunday,
so 12 combined during both days.
And we picked about 900 bags of dog droppings
between both days.
Yes.
I'm hoping 'cause it was winter, they were hard.
And cold.
There's nothing like a nice wet summer dog doo.
I know because I have dogs, and I foster dogs,
and I've had dogs.
I know gross, but you know what?
I also have babies and guess what?
They poo too.
(audience laughing)
But seriously, like what makes you do
what so many people turn away from and won't do?
Why are you such a good person?
Honestly, it was his idea.
But it basically came down to the point
that we are always walking there.
We live in Hoboken,
we work in Hoboken,
and it just got to the point that everybody was complaining.
And we're more problem-solvers
than actual people who just sit there and complain.
So we took the initiative and we went out there.
Originally it was supposed to be a group of us,
but you know, him and I make a great team.
And we went out there
and we just started picking up the dog droppings.
And you know, it ended up causing such an impact
in the community,
which you know, we were really happy about.
Yeah, you got yourselves on television.
I bet everybody was pretty bummed
they didn't show up after that.
Good things happen to good people.
You picked up 900 bags of droppings.
900.
900 bags!
Yes, and we actually made such an impact
that the Hoboken Business Alliance,
they contacted us via our social media,
which is Luv on a Harness,
and basically they said that they installed dogway stations
just because of what we did.
Yes.
(audience clapping)
We have a special message
from the Mayor of Hoboken, New Jersey, Ravi Bhalla.
Take a look.
Hello, I'm Hoboken Mayor Ravi Bhalla.
And today I want to send a special message
to Luis Perez and Nyomie Nievez.
It's sort of a pet peeve of mine
when owners don't clean up after their dogs.
So, the fact that you cleaned up
nearly 900 doggy bags of poop,
well, it's a load off my mind
and a load off our sidewalks.
You've gone above and beyond your due diligence,
and for that, myself and the city of Hoboken,
we are awarding you with an official proclamation.
Thank you so much, Luis and Nyomie,
you deserve a big round of applause.
(audience clapping)
That's awesome. That's awesome.
The Mayor. The Mayor.
And to make it official,
we got the proclamation from the Mayor to give to you.
Oh my God.
Nice.
So hang that on your wall.
Maybe show off to your friends.
Wow. Nice.
Wow, that's amazing.
Call up your friends who didn't show up
and say, we want you to come over
and look at our official proclamation from the Mayor.
And that's not all, our friends at Canidae Pet Food
want to donate $2,500 worth of pet food and snacks.
So you can share with your dogs
that you walk in your neighborhood.
Oh my god, that's awesome.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, this is awesome.
This is fantastic.
This is amazing.
What would you say if your dog goes to the bathroom
and you're hesitant to pick it up,
or you're being lazy, or you forgot a bag?
It's be a good neighbor.
Just, you know, take the initiative
and don't have the mentality of that's not mine.
You know, it's like, it's not only disgusting,
but it's unsafe for the children
and the elderly people in all the communities.
And you know, just picking up a little bit
next to, you know, your dogs,
it's something that could just make an impact.
I think they'll also step in some at another point.
All right, thank you Luis Perez and Nyomie Nievez,
for joining our Dr. Drewlittle hour.
You are what makes this so special.
Thank you so much for coming on.
And can we please stay in touch?
We're going to put you on the website.
Yes. Yes.
Thank you. Thank you.
Put your company on.
(upbeat music)